uh how are you doing
hi i'm good how are you
as good as you can be during a pandemic
yeah
i mean healthy exactly um good jumping
into why i get to talk to you because
obviously i only have a few minutes
uh one of the things that i think is
great about the first three episodes of
one division is that
it's a big swing it's not playing it
safe
it's it's going for it and it's doing
stuff that can only
be done on like disney plus you this
couldn't be a movie
could you sort of talk about the fact
that this is a big swing for marble
yeah i went when kevin proposed it to me
and it hadn't you know jack schaefer our
creator hadn't
hadn't fully fleshed it out i just loved
the idea
of wanda and vision trying to be normal
and not feel different and to fit in in
the suburbs
this whole other added sitcom element
is what makes it very confusing and it
is a really big swing
and it all leads somewhere and there is
a reason for all of it
and because of the beauty of television
we can guide and mislead and guide again
and continue to change those
perspectives for the audience but there
is a shift
that happens within those episodes um
and and there's more of more of those
kinds of shifts to come
yeah i was just going to say that for
people that are going to watch this
interview each episode sort of pulls
back
a little bit like hints at the bigger
thing with episode three hinting even
more
you know yeah but i know you can't say
much so
one of the things i wanted to talk about
though is that lo it was recently it
came out that loki will most likely get
a second season
and i'm curious do you think one
division could get a second season or is
it sort of called doctor strange too
um i that's funny um i don't think it's
called dr
strange too but um i guess the answer is
it could
i don't know i mean there's no i don't
have information
sure uh i i know you're in the middle of
filming i believe doctor strange too i
have to ask you
what was your reaction reading the
script for the first time
it was an excitement um i feel i think i
always start these jobs feeling
um in intimidated
by them being so um
large and then i find an
excitement to to get back in it but
they're intimidating sure well
well let me ask you uh i i'm very
excited that sam raimi
is is working in this genre again can
you please share what it's been like
working with him
and maybe what surprised you about
making so far what's been
about making doctor strange too um i
love
sam raimi he is really
a love first off he's a lovely person um
and i really enjoyed our
playfulness together of just kind of
allowing ourselves to discover
um new things and uh
he's a great energy and is a very
specific
filmmaker and loves playing with
his camera and it's it's been it's been
fun
got it i already got to stop can't wait
to watch the rest of the series
good luck with the rest of your
interviews thank you